president trump's ready for all-out war
with investigation crazed democrats on
capitol hill
and i have been the most transparent
president
and administration in the history of our
country by far
now the house goes and starts appearing
they want to know every deal i've ever
done
now mueller i assume for 35 million
dollars
checked my taxes checked my financials
which are great
well we're fighting all the subpoenas
look these aren't like
impartial people the democrats are
trying to win
2020 but they should be really focused
on legislation
if you want to litigate go after the dnc
crooked hillary the dirty cops
trump's fighting back against an
avalanche of democratic subpoenas
including one calling for former white
house counsel don mcgann
to testify about the mueller report
trump also saying that if democrats do
decide to impeach him
he'll fight it all the way to the
supreme court
democrats responding by ramping up their
rhetoric here's nancy pelosi
it's not about politics it's about
patriotism it's an
existential threat this administration
to our democracy in terms of our
constitution
i do believe that impeachment is one of
the most divisive
forces a path that we could go down to
in our country
but if the facts the path of
fact-finding takes us there
we have no choice but we're not there
yet
and maxine waters who's been screaming
about impeachment for two years
is as unhinged as ever
i know that as leaders they have the
responsibility
to try and hold our caucus together and
to try
and do and lead in the best way that
they think
will help us to be successful if they
believe
that now is not the time for impeachment
they'll keep trying and they'll go down
that road
we're gonna have to impeach i just wish
it was sooner than later
okay well we know what maxine thinks
greg
nancy i mean she's the leader of the
party in the house and she said that
this administration is an
existential threat to our democracy
that's correct what does that even mean
it's a very overused term existential
an existential threat asteroids uh
cataclysmic climate change islamic
terror
anytime you're stuck in an elevator and
maroon 5 is playing
existential threat but this is not and
the
suggestion that you are not a patriot if
you somehow disagree with this idea if
you don't join in the resistance we've
talked about this before
the expanding target of denigration
you are not a patriot let's go back to
2015
2016 having concerns about trump
made total sense right i had so many
concerns
he wasn't a politician his personality
he was a bull in a china shop he never
knew what he was going to do he had an
interesting colorful past
and plus you had all these other options
you had good options in the republican
party
you had safer options it didn't turn out
that way but concerns made common sense
now people are having the same concerns
three years later none of their fears
have materialized the world he has not
started any new wars
in fact he has tried to shrink our
military footprint he has not destroyed
the economy we have a booming economy
with the lowest unemployment
in modern history he's helped my
minorities and women
in that world so that so when you see
this kind of panic going on all you can
think about is
it's okay if you're a democrat i get it
it's team sports it's a
that's what you do but if you actually
believe this stuff i would say like a
never trump republican
it's emotional and it's irrational it's
stupid
and that's all i got to say juan where
do you think the democrats stand right
now and impeachment it looks like
they're
they're pretty split but no one can
actually
name the crime that they're impeaching
him for
we're talking about broad things like a
threat to democracy
that's not going to stick that's not
what we're talking about
i'm alarmed that you don't realize that
we're talking about obstruction of
justice but how did he do that
oh gosh he tried to tell don mcgann and
the point this is the point of great
concern right now he told mcgann to fire
mueller
so he didn't fire mueller no mcgann
apparently disobeyed his order now the
trump says nobody disobeys his order but
we've seen a little
wanting to fire someone which he has
every right to do under article two
wanting to fire someone is
obstructionist wanting to stop this
investigation this is something that i
hear sometimes
he ordered he calls up his lawyer
don mcgann and tells him to have the
attorney general fire
mueller because of conflict of interest
when there was no such thing going on
and mcgann saves him because it would
have been an
absolute fiesta how was he obstructed
well let me just say i mean even the
wall street journal this morning just
said you know they believe mcgahn now
trump is saying mcgann's not telling the
truth they say you know what
trump lies just so much and it
undermines his own credibility in so
many ways that's the wall street journal
conserved editorial page this morning
but let me just say there's so many
instances like this greg
says oh you know things are going so
great forget about
normal republican positions on things
like lowering the deficit or
not having all these trade tariffs or
not undermining democracy how's the
country going so far juan
i don't think that's going so well i
think that's why people are going to
have any evidence
and you say you also say greg oh he's
the most transparent
president ever if he's so transparent
why is he trying to stop don mcgann from
it because enough is enough
1.4 million documents everyone has
testified
he delivered written answers oh yeah
mueller looked at his taxes there's
nothing there
why are the democrats continuing to push
this issue when they
know that mueller saw everything he
needed to see what you can do is shout
because he wouldn't even talk to
tomorrow he he did not testify for
mueller
the point right now is that the
democrats are going to subpoena
so much information they're going to i
guess they could home again in you know
contempt of congress refuses to testify
but what the president and the white
house are doing is basically slow
walking it
and saying you know what we're a
stonewall will slow walk we'll end up in
the courts but we will not cooperate
that is not they've already cooperated
fully
mueller actually said that they had full
cooperation
and right now these two people mcgann
trump
special counsel they're all under the
executive branch
i mean there's no reason that they can't
just claim executive privilege and say
because they didn't claim it earlier
they can claim it whenever they want no
they can't
yes they can they will you ray will why
watch
because he didn't say that when it was
about mcgahn testifying
i'm just saying it's obvious here's what
the president has on his side if he
claims executive privilege for himself
or mcgahn moving forward
time and enforcement what i mean by that
is that subpoenas
and orders of contempt are being held in
contempt expires
with that congressional duration exactly
so all the president has to do is get to
january of 2021
and also it is the courts unlike the
supreme court's role
in impeachment which is zero obviously
for claims of
privilege or for subpoenas or contempt
they do play a part so he can absolutely
string it out and i think that's a
really
powerful tool because at the end of it
it will be
him and mcgann that shines rather than
congress who has nothing to show for it
okay and uh hillary clinton who uh did
not win the president oh really 2016.
she's written an op-ed watch news alert
she's written an ad an op-ed in the
washington post i believe yes
have you read it um i skimmed it right
before because it posted about 4 55 p.m
um basically she's saying uh hello
greg's got glasses on look at those
things this is my new glasses
i'm sharp i'm just waiting for somebody
to notice well professor gupta
yes professor gutfeld yes that's good
i'm sorry go ahead um i'm like he's
mesmerizing
[Laughter]
and he's very distracting dude i know i
like them taking them off hillary
clinton basically says
i know that i'm not necessarily the best
messenger um
yes i obviously lost and i think it's
due to russian interference but
i also speak as a former senator and a
former secretary of state and russia
russian interference is a big problem
but she's saying that congress should
basically go as far as they can to fill
in the gaps of the mueller report so
that's
the hillary clinton what gaps were there
i mean you know what i'm here to answer
i know i'm just i'm pondering myself
what gaps there were he was
there i think two years and it cost 35
million dollars i think it was pretty
exhaustive
bernie yes to that what i thought was
interesting was how she closed it which
basically said the most important part
the vital role is what the citizens play
and she used that to say
so therefore advocate for an impeachment
proceedings
rather than electorally which as we all
know how that
happened and benefited her you know what
this impeachment thing
it's only going to help trump because it
just
he just sees all the media turf to him
and i think it was was it sanders who
recognized
that first he said it's like we got to
start talking about our stuff
right this is just gonna and trump is
gonna eat this up right well
again wanting to do something is not a
crime and by the way there was no crime
charge so let's move on